c'est une image de plus en plus habituel
ici anaérobie cet employé de la ville
désinfecte l'espace public en asperge
même les médias qui arrivent avec leur
lot de mauvaises nouvelles
eh ben on attend tout va bien on veut
tuer tous les virus dit il
on utilise du chlore ce qui est assez
efficace en afrique on dénombre près de
2000 cas de corona virus sur une
population de plus d'un milliard de
personnes
ce n'est pas encore alarmant mais cette
pandémie invisible avant sournoisement
et en redoutent le pire dans les
prochaines semaines et c'est l'omerta du
silence
c'est une grande menace dit il c'est un
désastre en vue il faut gagner cette
bataille contre la copie 19
sinon ce sera dévastateur car les
systèmes de santé sur le continent reste
fragile et l'accès aux rares d'appareils
respiratoires sera quasi impossible
l'afrique du sud qui détient le plus
grand nombre de cas soit 402 a décrété
un confinement de trois semaines à la
population et pour cette vendeuse de
fruits et légumes c'est une demande
impossible iphone dans la haise ceux qui
ont des maisons peuvent s'isoler dit
elle mais pour moi ça veut dire mourir
de faim ou mourir du virus
les gîtes le deuxième pays le plus
touché avec 19 morts a déjà fermé ses
aéroports et ses établissements
scolaires mais ces cafés et restaurants
restent ouverts mais là on craint le
pire c'est au nigeria avec une
population de près de 200 millions
d'habitants c'est le pays le plus peuplé
d'afrique et ce virus l'epr on prend des
mesures préventives
ici on encourage les prières en ligne
mais rien à faire les églises restent
bond et on prie le bon dieu pour qu'il
éradique soderiz de la planète
rien ne m'empêchera d'aller à l'église
dit elle même si je suis la seule pour
le moment on dénombre 36 cas au nigeria
et à mort
les premiers cargos de tests de
dépistage et de masques sont arrivés sur
le continent gracieuseté du milliardaire
chinois jack ma est detecting case
australie il faut contenir la pandémie
dit elle et pour cela il faut la
détecter rapidement la ligne aérienne if
you pioneer lynx délivrera dans chaque
pays
vingt mille trousses de dépistage cent
mille masques ainsi que des combinaisons
de protection à usage médical car la
prévention est crucial ici à la bodega
qui sera du canada morin